TODAY, WE'RE GONNA
TALK ABOUT THE ALAMO
IN SAN ANTONIO, TEXAS.
1836--
ENTER WILLIAM TRAVIS.
DODGED OUT ON A BUNCH
OF BUSINESS DEBTS,
HE ABANDONED HIS WIFE
AND CHILD
AND HEADED TOWARDS TEXAS
WITH HIS SLAVE, JOE.
JIM BOWIE, HE FORGED
THESE DOCUMENTS THAT HE OWNED
ALL THESE GRANTS
IN THE UNITED STATES TERRITORY.
JIM BOWIE'S LIKE,
YEAH, THEY'RE ONTO ME HERE.
I BETTER GET TO TEXAS,
WHERE THEY'RE PROBABLY
NOT AS SMART,
AND I'LL START DOING THIS
SAME SHENANIGAN DOWN THERE.
CONGRESSMAN DAVY CROCKETT,
EVERYBODY LOVES THIS GUY.
THE SAYING GOES,
"HE COULD KILL A GRIZZLY BEAR
WITH HIS SMILE."
WELL, AS IT HAPPENS,
HE DOESN'T GET ELECTED
FOR A SECOND TERM.
AND HE SAYS,
YOU CAN GO TO HELL.
I'LL GO TO TEXAS.
CROCKETT, TRAVIS, AND BOWIE
HEAD TO TEXAS TO TAKE LAND.
MEXICO OWNS THE TERRITORY
OF TEXAS,
AND THE LONG-STORY-SHORT
IS THESE GUYS
EXPEL A MEXICAN ARMY
GARRISON
AND THEY TAKE A MISSION
FOR THEMSELVES.
AND THAT MISSION
IS THE ALAMO.
AND THEY HOLE UP
IN THE ALAMO.
BOWIE SAYS, DON'T WORRY.
THERE'S NO WAY
THE MEXICAN ARMY'S
COMING UNTIL SPRING,
BECAUSE THE WINTER'S TOO HARSH
ON THESE
HIGH MEXICAN DESERTS.
BUT THEY DO COME.
SANTA ANNA AND HIS SOLDIERS
ARRIVE IN SAN ANTONIO.
THEY'RE ON HIS LAND.
AND HE SAYS
TO THE ALAMO DEFENDERS,
SURRENDER NOW
OR YOU WILL BE KILLED.
[scoffs]
BULL[bleep].
LET'S FIRE A CANNON SHOT
AT SANTA ANNA
AND LET HIM KNOW
WE KNOW BUSINESS.
AND FIRES A CANNON.
AND THIS PISSES OFF
SANTA ANNA.